what's going on man what's happening
alhamdulillah you have question for I'll
leave it for today man I've like a
halfish so you don't believe do you
believe Jesus to be
God so you believe Jesus that is a he
has a perfect God
attribute so you I think you know that
Jesus doesn't know the hour Jesus he
didn't know the hour day of judgment so
when Jesus when Jesus said I don't know
the hour we believe that only the father
knows the hour does God know everything
yes is Jesus God yeah so God know
everything if Jesus Is God by if we have
to know everything correct it's a
question of you're asking me how huh
you're asking me house and uh house we
established today we can't we can't
answer how God no what I'm saying to you
I'm asking you how I'm asking you if if
you if if you
say uh what they call it single person
what definition of single person
definition of single person who is not
married Jal is single is he
married he's not because definition of
single person by default single person
means not married if Jamal is single
he's not married if ABD is single he's
not married all right
so now if God knows everything all the
time this the nature of God if Jesus Is
God by Def he has to know everything if
he doesn't know everything therefore he
cannot be God because by by God's nature
he knows everything so now which one is
it is Jesus God if he's good you have to
be consistent because you you and I we
agree that God knows everything by
Nature correct so therefore if Jesus Is
God you should know
what the point will be
everything yeah so how come it doesn't
know
the because it's helpful so therefore we
cannot be good CU you're just a family
doesn't know the hour and told me God
knows
everything it's a good point but I would
ask you to
answer my question yeah I was asking
this guy here question and he didn't I'm
not asking you how Jesus how God look by
the way or how God's face look I know
that's beyond our understanding we say
the way with his majesty see make
something clear because you say about
how no I'm not asking you how I'm asking
you there's something about God which
from his
nature what God what God is but anyway
you can go ahead um I was asking him
about uh you know when Allah send on to
the third heaven to the to the first
Heaven yes listen to the prayers no
listen he doesn't say listen no doesn't
is to respond not listen he listens to
listens to the time this is us now is he
not against his uh nature to descend
onto the heaven no he not why because
descending okay firstly the heaven is
what is the Unseen you agree yeah the
Unseen is and God is the Unseen okay so
we cannot comprehend the
Unseen the heavens created yeah but it's
from The Unseen how from The Unseen the
angels are
created we don't know how they look even
they are created they from the I was
saying Muhammad knows what the Angels no
no I'm not telling you who who knows my
point is the heaven is Created from the
unene okay so when God descends why
people try to say if God descends has to
go through this through that they are
utilizing they experience based upon
this creation to to apply it to the
Creator who doesn't make any sense you
understand that is a way difference than
God for example if I said to you that
descending also is not God nature
meaning that if God if God does not
descend if God never to us he doesn't
descend we still can utilize our brain
to know God knows everything all the
time yeah that's my point my point
descending because there different about
what God is and what God does what God
does does ever he wishes when whenever
he
Wills okay that God descends to the
lowest heaven in the F of the night but
know during the the morning time God
spoke to Moses he never spoke to you M
but what God is God is meaning that
that's his nature all the time this is
the problem with Christianity
Christianity go and guess what God is
not what God does what you tell me God
is from his nature that he knows
everything from his nature then you tell
me Jesus Is God but doesn't know
everything this is the big problem but
God
descending God say descend against his
not no he notc
to yes look his nature because you tell
me why is is because because I I want
say why I'm telling you God go against
his nature because all of us we know God
has the perfect knowledge so I'm
utilizing something that we agree on to
invalidate your belief but when it come
to descending I don't agree with you
that desending nature to begin with so
you say he can't enter the C no
okay watch this I'm just giv you example
even though it doesn't example this a
ring this is a bottle the ring is going
to descend from here to here he has not
entered the
bottle I mean he he has not entered the
bottle this is just creation brother but
I'm tell you here you cannot utilize
Allah descendant to the lowest Heaven
try to say no because this application
that you are applying or you try to
impose on God FAL notion this for is a
false notion this for creation not for
the Creator but when it comes to God's
nature is perfect understand if he
descends is not a
physical now you are using Greek
philosophy aristal point now aristal
said in his 10 rules if go if anything
that moves has to be a body and if it's
a body it's created that's not Jesus
statement it's not Prophet Muhammad's
statement you and I we should not use it
you have to go outside the book outside
in order to prove no not outside the
book no you have to go beyond you have
to go beyond ration try to invalidate
you don't have to be
physical and and we say God has Essence
but physical and this physical term what
do you mean God has Essence in reality
he exists independently yes does he does
he do actions yes but aristal said 11
rules or 10 10 rules 10 rules one of
them he start laying out what God should
not be or what makes something created
he mention if he moves there for is a
body if it's a body it has a part if
it's a part it's a body is creat and so
I'm just rephrasing by the way but the
point here is you when I tried when I
used I mean when when I refuted that
Jesus to be God the mighty messenger the
true Messiah I never use Aristotle I use
the Bible and the Quran the Bible and
the Quran both agree that God has a
perfect knowledge so you don't think
that God's hand of foot is a physical
hand off foot no what do you mean by
physical explain to me mean it's
real yeah or it's of course it's real
but doesn't mean like our hands like in
Arabic language we say the door has a
hand so you would say that God is
completely unical no I don't use this
term this term I never used it I use a
term that was used by Jesus and Moses
Abraham I don't use a term that was used
by the Greek philosophers this term
physical what do you mean by it for me
tell you if I do accept or not what do
you mean by I believe God has a physical
hand what do you mean by that
what you mean by yeah that's it if you
mean that it's real the way beit God yes
I accept but if you mean like created
and like a human beings or any creation
no I don't accept it cuz there's nothing
like God you see for example in the
Bible it said Jesus is on the right hand
of
God okay on the right hand of God and in
the Bible he mentions that God was
walking in the Garden of Eden M and the
Bible use that you see I'm going to tell
you he cannot be God because he was
walking okay because why we in the
Quran there's no verse in the Quran I
mean I have to use Quran Sunnah or even
scripture how come be using Aristotle
Aristotle was a misguided person he was
far away from the scriptures of Jesus
and Moses Abraham and Noah
anderi Jeremiah and Daniel so you say
this is a corrupted story of yes this no
no what I'm saying you are utilizing a
corrupted tool was used by a corrupted
individual aristot yes he was good at Ms
or whatever but when it comes to
speaking about Divinity and God and so
he was so far away talking
about yeah walk it no I'm not going to
negate it because the way God for
example in the Quan said the he no it
doesn't say walking according to my
knowledge he
says Allah will come coming on the day
of judgment affirm he will come okay how
Allah knows best
enter enter to us our judgments yeah Jud
is everything Allah be above everything
how Allah knows but what I will say to
you I respect you know I'm going to
hopefully you're going to think I'm
being rude or not I'm not rude what are
you doing we I just established to you
with a logical rational based upon
scripture Jesus cannot be God you went
instead of accepting anding know true
what you start doing you start trying to
utilize something which is unclear to
justify or to reject that which is clear
because talking about God moving or
doesn't not move this if I show I tell
you show me in the Bible said God
doesn't move and if he moves not God
doesn't say that it's Aristotle so why
we say to you Jesus is a mighty
messenger no doubt about that he's a
messiah no doubt about it but he's not
God and I can show you also why Jesus
cannot be God so from a logical point of
view all right cool watch this Jesus in
the was in the
earth he was asking the father for
what for help so Jesus was on the Earth
was he God as well yeah I know your
point I see I don't have the answer for
that's what I'm saying that's why you
know in the Quran show you the Quran you
know Allah said Allah mentioned a
powerful logical rational
argument Allah said about Jesus and Mary
both them used to eat food what does
that mean God is
self-sufficient if go if someone's in
need of something which is food that is
not the nature of the Creator who is
self-sufficient that go and gu his
nature of being
self-sufficient everything is in need of
God can I not flip it on you and say
that it's not God doesn't need to
descend to the first heaven so therefore
it's unbefitting of God to no one says
because a need to do it yeah no one said
that you're asserting a claim huh I
didn't say you needed to yeah but when
you why is eating food why is God
descending no food and descending is
different see what you're doing again
what you doing have respect you're
trying to descending okay it's a false
equivocation a false comparison yeah
they're both okay if I if I okay they're
both actions of what we are calling God
okay no descending does not invalidate
God's nature show me in the Bible
invalidate God's nature you're saying
that Jesus Jesus eating invalidates his
God nature yeah because you eat food to
what how do to replenish to
nutrition we don't necessarily have to
believe that he done that for that it
same thing about descend does he have to
descend no no no no you can't say does
God have to descend to does okay does
God have to speak to
Moses no okay so if I said to you can I
compare eating food to God speak it to
Moses imagine they're both things he
doesn't have to do but he does no but
food is something that okay to make it
clear to you yeah when Mary was holding
the baby Jesus and she was breastfeeding
him was that God yeah so was God was
getting breastfeed okay who he in need
of
breastfeeding no so his mother why was
he breastfeeding him for why it's the
same thing I can say to you why isend no
this sof Street you sof Street here I
can do it no no it's not it's not
because we know there's a need asking me
if I descend okay if I descend no not
descend if I walk from here to there
would that make me would that would any
person think Shi is weak doesn't but if
I say someone I'm eating everyone's
brain is going to thck automatically
when you eat food cuz you need nutrients
you need food come on bro like Jesus was
needing food Jes was need help all his
descendant to listen to the no no
problem show me what end okay is this so
why doesn't he just listen without the
sending okay why God doesn't not speak
to you directly without sending prophets
remember you cannot dictate to God what
you should do do no but eating food
you're doing the same thing with Jesus
you're dictating what he should no
problem it's eating food God's nature or
or human
nature it would be the human nature to
need to eat food to eat food okay so are
you saying Jesus eating food for the
sake of food just eating it yeah okay
show me in the Bible says
that it doesn't say in the Bible okay
well I know in the Bible Jesus EMP
himself and humbled himself to be like
us to be like us what when you eat food
because you need the food
yeah you see what you doing you are
trying to be honest and be sincere about
because we're going to die and it's not
a matter of cuz what's happening there
is two factors why people don't accept
Islam psychological factor or social
Factor psychological Factor you like
what you doing
exactly realizing doing it you not
looking for anything to justify your
position for for rejecting the truth I
mean like I I never came across no one
telling me trying to to compare God
descending to God eating food which
doesn't make any sense because when I
eat food I'm in need of the food okay
when God descends has nothing to do with
food with with other things he
understand listen not to listen doesn't
say that listen L to the no he doesn't
say to listen to the prayer Allah listen
to prayer from from downstairs upstairs
why he he says he descends to respond to
for the third of the night to respond
for the third night why so does he need
to do it to respond no doesn't need to
do it okay why because go God does
whatever he wishes that's my argument to
you not I because what what we're
talking about here what God is not what
God does what God is is self-sufficient
eating food go and guess what God is yes
descending is not what God is it's what
God does so differenti between the two
what God is is different than what God
does God I'm not telling you for example
his responding to the prayer yeah but
doesn't go and gu his nature what I'm
saying my point here is doesn't go and
gu his nature because Allah never said
I'm going to answer to your prayer the
thir of the night also is encouragement
for the people to wake up the thir of
the night that's what the say well so
it's encouragement it's not for God he
needs it it's to encourage you know so
the point here is that you are mixing
between what God is and what God does
what God is is perfect all the time what
God does he does whatever he wish
according to his nature according to his
wisdom and his knowledge but now what
God
is example imagine I said to you yeah
God he knows if he
wants oh doesn't make any sense because
God's nature to know everything if God
doesn't know he canot be God same God
knows everything but God he spoke to
Moses and even spoke to me but to you
God he destroyed some Nation but never
destroy other nation which go back to
God's actions you understand are you
with me with God what God is and what
God does all right so you keep sticking
to what God does you understand I'm
talking to you what God
is you telling me god is perfect but
when you look to Jesus is not
perfect God is not in need of no one but
Jesus was not in need of
help okay does do the father
eat why in the Bible father doesn't eat
doesn't eat food and also when you eat
food you know where you go to yeah
answer the cool of
nature yeah so I'm saying to you look I
mean like look even Mary let be honest
when Mary was holding have baby did she
believe he was
God we
believe so see she belied that this weak
baby she's taking care of him is there
anyone is God in need people take care
of
him so when Jesus was when Mary was
taking care of Jesus was that the same
God who was not in need of no want take
care of
[Music]
him it's not it wasn't a need though it
was a optional choice if she left him
without milk I would say it's the same
thing that God's choosing to descend no
if she left without if she left him
without a
milk God but this is God chose for it to
be like that no no if she left him
without to mil what will happen to
him this is this is a pointless this
question doesn't make sense no it makes
because he would die
the answer is no they wouldn't but so
she why she was feeding him just to give
her breast and anyway why why God
touching a woman
breast
is you're asking why no it's been noty
because why I respect because God
playing around touching woman breast I
mean come on
man Allah is far away from imperfection
you see what you're doing that which is
clear doesn't make any sense you try to
justify it that would that that which
makes sense you try to say why go doing
this come on we have to be honest
bro okay I'll give you something go when
Jesus was 5 years old did he know
everything see I don't have the answer
he was ignorant he was he know he was
learning cuz he went to the rabbis to
teach another day I'll look into it and
I'll come back to you the answer but for
me I'm sure the answer is that but I
don't have it on the answer is Jesus was
half man 100% human
100% God so they tell you I can help you
in a way I can tell you what they're
going to tell you 100 100% human he was
in need of cuz the argument you are
using I've been doing for the last 15
years no Christian missionaries no
scholar said this no one Tred to
equivalent to uh compare descending to
food no one did this in my life you're
the first person to do it it doesn't
make any sense you understand that what
they say to the Christians all of them
they say no Jesus was a man and about
the same time so when he was in need of
food that was a man
nature that's what they say but AR is
self- refuted because which part the
question which part of Jesus was God and
which part was a
man they tell 100% God 100% man that
doesn't make any sense because if I have
one if I have a ring 100% God it cannot
be 100% uh
silver or plastic cuz there things it's
the complete opposite
you understand so you cannot tell me a
man is created man is in need of food
you cannot be 100% a man and 100% God is
well and in the Bible it says Jacob said
oh God the universe cannot contain you
let alone my
temple yeah and is there anyone bigger
than
God no no one so when Mary was holding
Jesus who is bigger Jesus or the or Mary
right leave you man come to Islam come
to the come to the true teaching of
Jesus I will look I'll come back to you
inshallah take care of yourself but Pray
when we go home inah pray to the god of
Jesus the god of Abraham God of Muhammad
the god of everything to guide you
truth so Jes is not God because he has a
God but in the Bible Jesus said I'm
going to my God and your God does a God
have a god I don't have the answers for
you regarding I'm say rationality
rationality no no my question does God
have a God if God if we have a god of
everything does he have a God if he a
god of
everything I don't have the answer for
you come on bro you don't have to answer
for the simple things so that's why you
go into all the complex philosophy to
try
and yes I think you have an answer mask
that's the word I'm looking for that's
what you're doing was in your position
as well yeah he was that's what you're
doing you are Tred to mask the clearest
thing the simplest thing because the
question I'm asking you it's not a
question I'm not asking you the Bible
about scriptures about the manuscript
that's you have to study this I'm asking
you just use your intellect and your
natural
ination if is is Jesus the god of
everything sure is it the god of the
father so he's not the good of
everything I don't have the anwers for
Allah take
care open your heart